the National Football League is known
for its Legion of dedicated fan bases
like Cleveland's dogpound the bills
mafia and Buffalo and the Terrible Towel
waving fans of the Pittsburgh Steelers
but one group takes it to another level
we're talking about the infamous silver
and black clad fans of Raider Nation but
their devotion has been in question with
the team playing its last game in
Oakland tomorrow before moving to Las
Vegas we met up with some of the Raiders
most hardcore fans to see what their
future with the team might be welcome to
an Oakland Raiders game day at the
Coliseum not exactly the typical NFL
tailgate experience and not exactly the
typical NFL fans guerrilla Rilla on an
on game day is also known as mark Acacio
been dressing up since 95 in Oakland
have missed the preseason or regular
season I missed my my son's wedding
because of a Raider game you missed your
son's wedding yeah because of a radar
yeah Acacio isn't alone in his utter
devotion to the Raiders
there's also Cathy Sandlin skull lady
fifty-three years from me fence colony
419 Charles ybarra dark Raider there was
original dark Raider in the 70s yeah I
had to be the guy that carried along
that legacy so twenty four years later
he never missed a game and Wayne Mabry
violator been violated for 28 years
that's meant nearly three decades of
this rising before dawn on NFL Sundays
to quite literally put his game face on
this isn't just a fandom it's a parlor
if you can in just one word the Raiders
are family familia mm-hmm family family
for the last 24 years from the black
hole in one end zone to the dark side on
the other they've brought the
oakland-alameda County Coliseum to life
and in the process made it infamous
going into the black hole as an opposing
quarterback what was that like you know
I hated playing there when I was with
the cheese
CBS NFL analyst Rich Gannon played for
the rival chiefs for four years before
becoming the Raiders quarterback in 1999
I love playing there as a Raider I would
sit there and watch the opposing
quarterbacks or the opposing teams I
just thought to myself now you know what
it feels like I have to say it's it's
intimidating you come walking out of the
tunnel and they're right there they're
waiting on you and they just don't stop
they're relentless
is that I mean cuz they're not gonna get
on the field they're not gonna touch you
but it really does get to you it does it
wasn't just the crowd noise it were some
of the comments that would happen that
were very personal in nature that
environment has been called into
question labeled as violent not
family-friendly even dangerous I think
in the beginning I was a little bit
rough you know people weren't really
sure to know what kind of radar nation
was an Oakland there there were some
ruffians we kind of educated them to be
something more
some of Raider Nation blames the media
for perpetuating the worst stereotypes
sighting a few Bad Seeds spoiling it for
the whole bunch but there was an
intimidation factor it always went along
with the black hole
maybe not the friendliest of names
yelled out it opposing players is that
fair or the refs hey there well people
don't see is actually their point of
look at what way if they came in there
and we were quiet real mild-mannered it
wouldn't be the same these opposing fans
and and players have stories to tell
about us so the seed has been planted
growing a home-field advantage that's
both misunderstood yet effective
according to former Raiders CEO Amy
Trask
embraced by fans as the princess of
Darkness so many times members of the
national media executive
of other teams would express to me
concern about some of the characters
they saw and I would laugh because hey
go ahead and be scared I kind of like
that and be if you only knew the people
you were expressing these trepidations
about the woman that you thought was
going to eat you in the parking lot was
an assistant district attorney right you
know the gentleman who scared you a bit
Department of Homeland Security these
are magnificent people but the
intimidation without a doubt is there
absolutely absolutely the home-field
advantage that they create actually
translates into yardage when our
opponent would have a delay of game or a
false start
that was crowd driven every single fan I
saw from that moment on I said thank you
for that yardage thank you for those
five yards because they delivered it the
Raiders current head coach John groovy
has a similar appreciation personally
recognizing Raider Nation whenever he
can when we went on going down there and
when we lose usually I stick around the
parking lot and hang out with the guys
and you know try to get him ready for
the next home game I like to share my
joy with some joyous Raider fans as much
as possible more than a team in its fans
family one that's been feuding ever
since the team's decision to relocate to
Las Vegas
the move was announced in 2017 leaving
the Raiders to play the last three
seasons in front of the Oakland crowd it
would leave behind for me it'll never be
the same
I don't care where they move to it'll
still be my favorite team my best love
but as far as here this is Mecca this is
Holy Grail to me the last three years
vanished like
you know cheating on you but you ain't
catching her catch her mark that does
not sound like something I want to be a
part of are you mad at the Raiders no
I'm not mad I understand this it's
business
it took me some time we've all known
some fans that have just are done
they're completely done yeah I mean it
that was it that was the last straw from
when you just said you know you're it
took you a while you were angry but then
you were able to move on and you all say
this is family and isn't that what we do
with family Yeah right know that yeah
yeah if your family moves out of state
are you gonna stop loving them no we're
not gonna stop loving our Raiders and
we're not gonna stop following them
we're diehard show of hands how many of
you will be at that opening game in
Vegas mm-hmm now look there are people
that left these diehards are going some
even live closer to Vegas so to be an
easier trip for them to get there but I
think the thing to remember with these
this fan base there is well known as the
players they've been with the team
longer than these players right now
people seem in the parking lot it's
guerilla Rilla come over here darth
raider come over to me Gruden knows them
the ownership knows them they really are
a part of the family this isn't their
first move
I mean they've moved right Los Angeles
and back back to Oakland right and the
difference now is whether or not Vegas
will be the same atoms located come
ahead some of their comments were so
personal